so she's she's a she's a 10 but minus 10
because she's my man's wife in it okay
okay
um spiritual lady how do you know I'm
spiritual because you got a weird
necklace on with shapes
you're talking about like your star sign
and like challenge in generals stuff
like that
um
I'm gonna stop at the first one actually
now you gotta write everybody okay
Atta
four
uh
three
oh my lucky enough
also also I don't I don't know you so
personality is like three points
now we're just going based on looks but
just looks
I can't believe I'm doing this now
you're hating you're feeling hard on
them you are hating so much
sex oh that's because she's tall I like
I like I like height
I'm six one
if
[Laughter]
he's a wife you could you could I want
to see I'm fine it's up to you guys you
can pick you don't have to participate
if you don't want to participate I don't
go ahead okay what does handling I'm
just curious how many women raise
themselves and then I'm gonna have the
women raid each other too
where do I stop okay
um right I'm gonna start with the novel
tell me the novel
[Music]
um tell me I'm ready I'm gonna give the
novel an adjustable seven ah and
adjustable what does adjustable mean so
you know so you know depending on what
she says on a particular time
like on a normal day you know fresh face
no makeup I'll say a seven but she you
know when she gets you know spruced up
you know she could get that eight nine
in there maybe it's an adjustable one uh
let me go from
yeah yeah
um what's your name sorry me yeah
Valentina Valentina oh that name might
have just given you an extra point
s
6.5
Valentino was like oh it's a nice name
um in the middle here um
based on what I'm looking at right now I
don't know because I did say you just
came from a shoot
so I mean I don't have like Foundation
or not yeah so I'm gonna just say five
and call it a safe five okay yes say
five you know
um
Naomi rabbit man
[Laughter]
yeah exactly
I'm not friends with people we're not
friends what we are friends we're
acquaintances of course like you're my
peoples and you're my brethren in it my
brother that's what I'm saying yeah it's
love but you know being friends with
females is tough
um
let's not get into it
um Naomi I'll give a Naomi a
[Music]
7.5
yes
I think 97.5
and
that was tense yes it was
um
no no I'm gonna nah nah I'm gonna
continue man I'm gonna rate everybody on
the panel
um
based on based on the information that I
have received so far
she gets a nine
and the reason why she gets a nine
because one she has a ring so that
automatically just puts Five Points
right
[Laughter]
um and um what you were saying about how
you would go into like a just just the
kind of honest devotion that you've
given to your husband and the respect
that you've given him and told him like
even if he wasn't here my [ __ ] would be
messed up that's that nine that's that
nine that's a nine bro so bro let's
celebrate love oh my God it's so cute
yeah all right what about you
all right respectfully I won't even rate
his wife I don't have no respect no I
don't respect I'm joking I wouldn't meet
his wife I'll give Naomi a solid eight
yeah I'll give
sorry what's your name the blonde one
sorry
Bella I'll give you a uh I'll give you a
solid five and a half
and I'll give your friend six
and I'll give you a solid eight
see what I'm saying
quick and simple okay now question no no
question for the girls so okay the girls
have to close your eyes
close your eyes close your eyes close
your eyes I like this okay okay
um
so if you open your eyes you're gonna be
subbed out yeah oh yeah there's a sub
there's a sub so you'll be subbed out if
you open your eyes all right
um from the couch on the left you guys
remember where everyone's sitting yeah
yeah yeah so I was on I would come I'm
sorry I I forgot some of your names I
won't lie to you but polish girl all
right all right put your hand up for how
what you rate her wait would you like
put like one like with we'll put both
your hands yeah fingers put your fingers
foreign
[Music]
Naomi put your hands up
okay
um
the blonde I'm sorry I'm so sorry about
it
okay Arabella Arabella with a height
okay keep my eyes closed yeah eyes
closed eyes closed eyes closed this is
so stressful okay
okay and then right what's what's the
question the other rating one to ten
wait who are we on uh
what's your rate in the novel you're
supposed to put your fingers up with
what you're rating
you close your eyes
close your eyes Okay and rate how much
you think the other girls look the
number with your fingers
the blonde girl on the couch the blonde
girl on the couch okay wait so I haven't
seen anybody I haven't read today I
thought you were asking people to open
their eyes Okay Okay
um you had a very pretty name but I
don't remember what it was Valentina
Valentina Valentina
um everyone go
um
okay dinamo what do you put for
Valentina put your hands up okay wait oh
my God please
okay now everyone do denalva
okay okay thank you guys that's it
that's it nobody didn't do the rest I
didn't do the rest are we allowed to
open up yeah you can open your eyes it's
just interesting I just it's interesting
to see what the men put the women put
and then like what you guys put
this back guys
[Laughter]
all right as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible